die frage steht natürlich die die
geldfrage
herzlich willkommen zum teil 3 meines
interviews mit lea die ganze sache dreht
sich darum dass lehrer im jahr 2020 bei
den bachelor und dazu habt ihr einige
fragen gehabt lehrt bereit erklärt ihr
euch zu beantworten ganz wichtig vor der
kläger sind im bestand von dem taxi
gerne ab und jetzt leute viel spaß mit
den fragen wie immer eine frage die
wahrscheinlich unter schweige klausel
fällte wahrscheinlichkeit kannst du dich
schon mal nein sagen kann zweck
irgendwas sagen was bereits einige
fragen stellt natürlich die die
geldfrage
das ist wahrscheinlich gut unter
verschluss okay aber es klang alles ja
meistens aus wobei die glasproduktion
dass da nicht nicht informiert wird
darüber was sie das irgendwie da schon
genau bekommt ihr könnt es auch mal
wirklich dazu im vorfeld noch mal eine
google da gibt's ja artikel mit zur
größenordnung weiß nicht wie genau die
sind ob google das auf den punkt was
passiert am ende mit der rose ja anders
sind
wie war das auswahlverfahren ja genauso
bewerbung dazu beworben da gab es ein
casting genau also ich hab mich beworben
das wird ja minuten eingeblendet hast du
lust den mann kennenzulernen nächsten
staffel
wenn ich die online seite gegangen da
musst du bilder einreichen und
vorstellungsvideo und kurzer
internationalen
das wurde dann ab verschickt und dann
hat es tatsächlich so ein fragebogen den
ich per e mail bekommen hat
wenig tage komplett ausfüllen musste ich
ja nicht auseinandergenommen recht also
alles alles gefeiert
also meinst du meinst also in dem sinne
leute kennenlernen oder mainz im sinne
von auch so psychologisch ist ja schön
also irgendwas steckte dafür stimmt also
zb mit ihren artikeln veröffentlicht so
dass das leder und sie möchten dieses
jahr die haben erst einen artikel
veröffentlicht den ich mir hat im
vorfeld einmal durchgelesen habe und
manche so den schick auf gar keinen fall
ab das entspricht nicht der wahrheit was
ihr da entstehen und da habe ich eine
frage der frage ob ich kann es mir nur
so erklären
da stand es um finanzielle absicherungen
oder lieber in einem anwesen dann mache
ich so
ich suche beides aber ich möchte diese
finanzielle absicherung zusammen mit
meinem partner aufbauen
ich suche sie jetzt nicht dahingehend
dass der partner mich finanziell und die
haben tatsächlich dann in diesem artikel
geschrieben
wer seine loyalen man dazu ihr steht als
ich finanziell absichern und nun der rat
dann macht er sich mal sind die möchte
ich nicht öffentlich kam und die haben
erst veröffentlicht weil es fehler gab
ich bin natürlich durch die decke dann
weiß man also man könnte es nicht anders
interpretieren was ich da geschrieben
und ich finde eigentlich dass ich
deutlich gemacht haben was ich damit
meinte
ja das war dann sehr stressig für mich
und da wartet mit der situation in der
ich dann doch mal hochfahren kann und
sauber werden kann was wirklich sehr
selten vorkommen
sie haben das zum glück dann auch gern
hat genau das war die st
daher nehme ich dann nicht mit fragen
aus mangel genommen dann schickt leben
bekommst dann nochmal ein anruf glaube
ich war das und wird zum persönlichen
casting
köln war das und da sind dann
verschiedene räume werden verschiedene
interviews mit ihr geführt
du musst outfits präsentieren und dann
bekommen sie zu hören
jeder punkt wahrscheinlich kocht fragen
will ich will aber es waren tatsächlich
für die sauberkeit vor ort selbst
zuständig das heißt wenn wir nicht
geputzt hätten mir ist nicht sauber
gewesen aber wir waren zum glück damit
zum größten teil sehr sehr ordentlich
ich habe noch einmal auch mal sind
gefallen das war echt eklig wenn
irgendwo eine schüssel stehen gelassen
ich musste selbst putzen ist für mich
ein würstchen also den wert was die da
irgendwie ein carlin mexiko also service
kannst du noch günstiger als deutsche
unternehmen haben oder so wahrscheinlich
wollte jetzt aber doch ein bisschen
testen noch mal so ein extra extra
gesprächspunkt leider kann
da haben ja oft personen verschiedene
ansichten was sauberkeit lassen ehe ich
nach agieren mussten selbst wenn die
sauberkeit zusammen fort nächste frage
ist wahrscheinlich auch eine frage die
verschwiegenheit ist thematisiert aber
vielleicht kannst du darüber reden ohne
was konkretes zu sagen leer ist oder so
fragt was war das erschreckendste im
vertrag
anders formuliert weil darüber kann
passiert nicht reden gab es allgemeine
sachen wo die würde dies faktisch geht
das wenige was ist das so dass hatte ich
war schon zu sagen was ist das das geht
ja verstanden also welche klauseln wenn
man sich das eigentlich alles klar macht
sind unter anderem besten natürlich das
kann nicht anders sein ist die eine
verschwiegenheitserklärung drin
die erinnern ist so wie es auch bei
überhaupt dpa zwei kleine produktionen
also das ist nicht drin
genau deswegen gibt es auch viele punkte
über die wir nicht reden dürfen
leider leider leider victoria 285 waren
welche da also mit jetzt kandidatinnen
gemeint die eigentlich nur ins fernsehen
kommen wollten und vielleicht gar nicht
so ein interesse daran hatten auch hier
ist aus diplomatischen gründen
vielleicht keinen namensnennung aus
löst das aber gab es leute bei denen wir
gedacht haben sie wirklich interesse an
dem also in kaster liegen ja wenn man
sich für ein tv programm anmeldet dann
muss jeder irgendwo lust haben im
fernsehen zu erscheinen
sonst macht das ja gar keine sind sich
dann zu hören sonst kann es hier einfach
kinder lohnen und hier rechts und links
zweiter aber im großen und ganzen hat
die schon den eindruck dass auf jeden
fall jeder von den frauen die chance
gegeben hat sich persönlich vorzustellen
weil man kann ja nicht erscheint
klinikum optisch nicht nur misstrauen
sagen wie lange ich noch versöhnlich
angeguckt und geschaut ob das passt
einige sind dann noch freiwillig zu
sagen hat ihn für sich entschieden haben
dass das nicht der richtige mann
im großen ganzen unterstelle ich da
keine frau dass sie jetzt wirklich
ausschließlich nur da war um ins
fernsehen zu kommen freut sich im doppel
gezwungen wurde zu räumen
hast du es wurde alles nicht geschnitten
oder oder oder
zusammenhalt dauernd einsatz von dem
rhein gedrückt dass ich das passiert
wenn ein arzt das georgianum substanz
abgebauter unseres an zu dem kaiser
prüfen auf welche freunde
passiert war das motto des theaters man
rosa können sie das kann ich eine stunde
entscheiden so wenig gezeigt weil ich
wurde dann auf die schiene gedrückt das
möglich sind diese zu kühlen kühlen
werden die so leicht los hat und so
vögeln vertrag steht tatsächlich ist
an der stelle muss ich kurz darüber
sprechen weil es uns vielleicht
schwierigkeiten geben könnte leute also
jeden fall ist es so dass man für
verhütung selbst zuständig ist emily
bier war passt die wirklich so komisch
wie möglich kommen
also ich glaube dass uns noch nicht
sagen
er hat ja durchaus bisschen mehr
kritiker bekommen als bachelor vorne und
der wurde komplett zerrissen
okay nicht nur ein bisschen kritik ja
ich habe im sommer so die firma sollte
wurde komplett zerrissen von den medien
als auch einfach von deutschlands einen
monat also ich kann zu dem zeitpunkt
sagen als ich ihn getroffen habe
da war das auch dieses ganze genre noch
nicht bekannt so dass er wirklich ein
netter typ war ein netter bodenständiger
mann
ich hätte ihnen auch nicht geküsst wenn
ich da jetzt immer super dramatisches
ende gefunden hatte und ich finde
persönlich super schade dass ich finde
er sehr ungünstig auch erscheint und
fernsehen also können es werde zum
beispiel viele sätze von minus 24 grad
wird es werden solche viele
besserverdienende zeigt wie einfach
dramatischen fehler eingebaut und wir
haben viele tolle sehr ernste gespräche
geführt mit guter thematik und gefühlt
wird nur sehr oberflächlich gezeigt was
ich für ihn sehr sehr schade finde man
mag jetzt von ihm halten was man möchte
aber man muss bitte immer bedenken dass
es wirklich nur ein kurzer
zusammenschnitt aus der ganzen zeit ist
was das fernweh gezeigt wird glaube es
hätte zwischen uns nicht so gepasst wie
es damals dachte weil auch wenn ich
jetzt dieses sprüche nochmal reflektiere
hat merke jetzt dass vielleicht die
wellen denken auch nicht so gar nicht
richtig uns vielleicht auch und zum
missverstanden haben einfach von den
gesprächen her und da ist es natürlich
so wenn man dafür ist dass da 21 frauen
und nun nur diesen ein mann passt dann
kritisierst du denen auch also nicht das
heißt kein guter typ sage aber trotzdem
bringen die sportlich dass noch mehr
diese viele aufzumachen das eine sache
für angebot und nachfrage
ja sicherlich auch gewaltig und
wirtschaft studiert leute das sind
nämlich sind diese folie links und
oliver polizei will muss genau das ist
eigentlich ein monopol
es geht ja irgendwas gutmann und dann
gibt es einen anbieter- und viele
nachfrage quasi jeder situation also
dieses monopol gefehlt vielleicht hat
man auch noch mal schneller gefühle
aufgefordert weil man muss ja auch
einfach bedenken ich hatte jetzt zwei
gruppen des und zwei einzelsitzen und in
46 kann allerdings durch liebe diesen
mann
er ist jetzt an zukünftige ehemann ich
kann nur sagen dass ich den sehr
interessant fand zu dem zeitpunkt und
ihn gerne noch weiter kennengelernt
hatte und interesse an ihm hatte
allerdings ist jetzt alles noch mal
schlussendlich reflektiere merke ich
jetzt so vielleicht doch so punkte waren
die einfach zwischen uns nicht so gut
gepasst hätten nicht zu dem zeitpunkt
aber einfach nicht bemerkt habe und
damit sollte er jetzt auch teilhaben so
interviewserie das ganze leben ist
vorbei
leas und checkt sie auf jeden fall ab
finanzfluss mitmachen dann kriegt ihr
darüber ein völlig vorstand conti mica
bonn ihren wobei noch nicht ganz
schlüssig sollte ich mich dabei aus dem
schnitt um die zehn minuten voll machen
zu können und mir dementsprechend mehr
konzerten für die kommende corona krise
leisten zu können
eine sache leute wenn ihr ideen hat mit
wenig in zukunft mal interviews machen
sollte aus nämlich in fernsehsendungen
oder sonst wo man kommt ja mittlerweile
auch an viele leute raten dann jobs
einfach in die kommentare
dadurch fürs zuschauen
[Musik]